e non sia stato smith amico se vieni da
in questo un primo video un video strano
ragazzi questo è un video strano perché
in realtà secoli enti nel 1800 io e ai
buffo chi kesicki ai bucchioni fiorello
che oggi sarebbe ai buffi luca fa schifo
essere chiamato ai puffo perché si
vergogna di aver scelto quel nickname
tempo fa ai buffoni serate convinto a
chiamare mente rompiscatole tra il mezzo
davvero a distanza tipo di due secoli
abbiamo deciso di rifare una partita uno
verso su 16 a ragazzi abbiamo veramente
bravi mv 2 giocavamo delle partite
epiche andiamo a disinnescare diamoci
tutti qua da andiamo davanti dai fai tu
il vinci 6 ma la bomba dedicarla a
disinnesco io faccio io faccio io faccio
no
facevo io lei ha preso la bomba o anche
questo coso grosso per sparare alle
persone grosse e ucciso uno con un ayami
sono ucciso ma hanno ucciso dai luca è
tutto nel bravo bel c'è scritto che
abbiamo vinto rock am ring e niente
quindi faremo sta partita qui per vedere
chi vince alla meglio di tre quindi
faremo tre mappe di call of duty la
prima e rast faremo ai grace e la terza
la vela decidiamo li penso all'arbitro e
tu sei la per casualità è vero non avrei
tradotto morti era lì a caldo sulla
professione mi chiamano le partite
private divenuto per l'arbitro è mai
l'arbitro
da allora si gioca 20 uccisioni chi
vince chi ne fa 20 per primo e si fanno
tre mappe adesso questa la prima dai
abbiamo mai prodotto da cecchino però
solo cecchino ebete only sniper per su
sei puffi ai puffi è calcolato fatica de
merda dice senza riscaldamento senza
fare stiano dai noi siamo pro players
prima bravo bravo eh sì no no
madonna barisardo altro più mesi anni
che non c è vero sono passati solo due
giorni
allora basta cgia se triste no non è
vero come quando un suo commento preso
attraverso tutto a [ __ ]
no ma non meno scout
lo scopo a carissimo non ci è venuta un
po scarso al caro luca cosa ho fatto
io non sto facendo un culo porca eva da
dove sei uscito da un bastardo e fai lo
sfigato re di coltelli no ma porca vacca
raid ha davvero tra l'altro come cazzo
sono i corpi sulle mv due bellissimi ma
lorenzo capendo però è però vetrai e
bellissimo noti spostatisi ma come cazzo
fatto non prenderti che era di utilità
stanchi e niente niente
si no vince ma porca vacca layla ma i
predator
minchia bellissimo
ma qua si è impiantato il coltello c'è
ma si può ma do in faccia nel fatto che
quantità sempre insieme
no a larghe purissimo un bel ali la
partita passata coltelli in faccia
voleva lorca borga [ __ ] mori del
borghetto eroi a 6
non so ma la cruda fate giro
improponibile dai sempre lì
niente l'ultima è si sa già abbiamo
visto ora arriva dai va bene va bene
molto bene la prima andata bene dai 20
quindi ormai che ne facciano 3 poi
ripigliati ma se perdo tutte e due di
fila cioè un culo ai gravi tutti i
contributi e facciamo vale per la
prossima vedremo dai vai dentro anche tu
hai la sensazione come se non sapessi
giocare perché è appena iniziato e si
completa partite mi sono ripreso perché
sì anche perché avete ripreso una mano
si anche io non ho fatto
beh mica detto nella merda alla fine
solo di 5 se quella sfida epocale c'è
mai successo nella storia
oddio hai deciso hai deciso di partire
così ho deciso che la morte rapida
soluzione doveri
ho visto partire un coltello ma cosa
probabile ma per favore fate largo
oddio no vabbè dai ma farlo presto
hai visto il coltello non riusciamo a
beccarsi a oh oh oh no bastardo che culo
di di dino scopo solo lino stop ma
[ __ ] se veniva questa pardo che si
equilibra te no ma cazzo o dai come ho
fatto mancare come ma adesso rimasto
fermo sono stato scemo io bellissima di
aiuto
tra di fila se nei fantastici mi colpì
banda larga ma dalle sue notti mi
riprende non è vero e grave sembra dai
di montone di montone 15 8 rimontona
deciso ma dove cazzo eri no no no
e che cosa dai [ __ ] e 92 non è
vero se va bene se ma che cazzo a posto
poi poi poi quando si va da ragazzo 6 ma
eri lì ma non ebbe non è noi mica io sta
partita fatto la mente schifo non è
riuscito a prenderti in anche mentre non
guardavi punto la registriamo la
tensione no noi li butta [ __ ]
pensavo fossi nato dall altra parte e
vabbe dai colori schiara 20 16 dai 11
minimale o favero tempo a vela favela
papa però un bordello
ok questa è la partita del secolo
abitano lì c'è c'è ancora l'arbitro è
morto a partire prego scambiatevi gli
scudetti ma è anche il fischio d'inizio
non lo so se vuoi che se ne va bene ma
va bene così ma ricordo neanche più
favela l'ho fatta lo di 96 anni fa ma
smettila non c'entra c'entra
dichiaro addio mi è arrivato un cortese
no vabbè che vendeva che il culo
ma cosa faccia o meno ma dai
l'ho visto volare solo cascato dal tetto
affanculo
ma come cazzo fate come piume canzone ci
da ioan 30 questa volta perché feccia
provoca quello ecco fatto bene uccide ma
porca [ __ ] ma sempre di sera mi ero
sempre no bastardo ho detto e lo facevo
ho visto spuntare sono tesi a per un
nanosecondo ogni caso madonna come cazzo
hai fatto che non è possibile punti
pensavi facessi lo zanza invece no lo
zampino
non è vero ma se non riuscivo a morire
così guarda mi dava olimpica c'è un
gioco tipo cavalli simulator modo ma
come cazzo problemi ming problemi ma che
cazzo ci fai
ma fare sterili e cosa che dovete dare
ma come mai
ma come fa un secondo prima sai nel coso
come fai e sugli aerei e rimontato tutto
6 cassetti
basta basta e troppo mondiale nucleare
sforzo quick tabs ma [ __ ] lo stavo
in vantaggi simone fatto 16 di fila non
è possibile
ma punta [ __ ]
ma perché ma cosa che atene rimane uno
die ecke azzolini non così ma con 8 10
cdt va comunque sia corti ha già
decretato vincitore che vince perché
l'altro giocare con lo sporco un giorno
savino lo sporco ha vinto lo sporco
vinto sporco sconfitto lo sporco ha
vinto è stato bello comunque ride molto
ma niente ragazzuoli io conclude a
concluderli video in una maniera che
proprio di disgusto interna che ognuno
lasciare se io sono fortunato in altre
cose tipo nell'acquistare banane a un
prezzo più favorevole su k per il resto
vuol dire che possiamo concludere qui
non credo qui vito ragazzi sparami che
vi sia piaciuto anche sarà un po diverso
ma andava fatto perché era dopo andiamo
però te la do pubblico o niente noi
ceniamo non prossimo e lasciate come sei
tu come tu mi piace anche la pace di
facebook mi vide torna nelle scuole ci
vediamo cosa video e ragazzi
azzi cosa sta succendo la macchina mi
spiega eva peron e fisica questa
qualcuno mi spieghi cos'è aiuto e non
posso neanche guidarla